hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Game of Thrones episode 5 QA just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet so here we go I saw a
lot of you guys asking questions about
the next episode supposedly benjin was
appearing on IMDB because I am DB is so
unreliable I'm just taking the
wait-and-see approach but George R
Martin has said that he did not say that
Benjen is dead so effectively he's still
alive and will come back I think we'll
see him again through Brants storyline
because he's the only person north of
the wall right now on - Hodor things
though here we go do p asks that was
heartbreaking are we gonna see a
resurrected white Hodor I think the
implication is is the night's king
raises every dead body that he can find
every what virtually every one is turned
into the army of the Dead when you think
about it it does sound like a giant
middle finger in the face of Hodor
sacrifice so what bigger WTF could you
imagine then a couple episodes down the
road you see a white Hodor that doesn't
mean they're gonna do it but it would be
a really easy slam dunk if they wanted
to piss everyone off
next question Nathaniel asks why did the
direwolf die as I won't drop that f-bomb
especially in the way that it was
ducking atrocious and I like the way you
didn't use the f-bomb the second time so
the interpretation that I'm taking is is
the direwolf's die after the start
children do something bad or perform
some falsehood the first example is
Sansa lady died after Sansa lied about
what Joffrey did so the consequence of
her lying is that lady died bran did
something he was not supposed to do in a
bunch of people died even Isaac
Hempstead right the actor was like nice
one dude seriously Robb Stark broke his
vow to marry a Frey married Talisa
instead thank Rae wind winds up dying so
things like that the stark children do
something bad in as a consequence the
direwolves die
next question boo boy asks how will
brand go back in time to finish the
tower of joy flashback so I saw a lot of
people confused about this brand has all
the powers of the three-eyed Raven so if
the three-eyed Raven was taking him into
the past
bran can do that on his own - before the
episode I'd assumed he needed to touch a
weirwood in order to flashback but as we
look at them they're running away he's
still in the past while Hodor is holding
the door so in this moment he's still in
the past without touching
we're wood so it sounds like he only
needs weirwoods to initiate but once
he's in there physically in the present
his body can be moved around
he doesn't have to keep touching the
weirwood but just to be clear when the
three-eyed raven says it's time for you
to become me he's trying to upload all
of his knowledge into brans mind and
bran will probably figure it out over
the rest of the seasons Dan and Dave
clarified after the episode that bran
just doesn't understand how to use all
of his powers which is why he got into
trouble with the night's king next
question and asks this is actually a
good one the Bloodraven states that bran
is marked after being touched by the
night's king and is this the reason why
the magical barrier that keeps them from
entering the cave fails do you think
that since the same type of magical
barrier keeps the White Walkers from
travelling south of the wall if bran
were to travel south the White Walkers
could follow him and do you think this
is the reason we haven't seen Benjen so
I definitely agree with the mark like
that's why they were able to cross the
barrier the first time I think that we
could also assume that that's why
they'll be able to cross through the
wall too there's not enough evidence to
say that's why benjin hasn't come back
yet but it would be one explanation for
why he hasn't even been in a line of
sight with any other people because he
could find a way to communicate with the
Nights Watch even if he couldn't come
back but the way the Bloodraven explains
it to brand he makes it sound like when
the night's king marks you it enables
him to track you so it's definitely
plausible that that's why benjin hasn't
tried to seek out any of the Nights
Watch
next question Dany asks the guy who
became the first white Walker looks far
too modern we have all these medieval
looking characters and then we have a
modern looking dude who's in good shape
despite being a war prisoner from a time
well before now so you're just saying
you think he'd look more like tormund
Giantsbane or something like that you
know like not supercut well I think that
they're just taking a little creative
license because they want him to look
good on screen they bend a lot of rules
when it comes to historical accuracy one
of the best examples is that they did
not have toothbrushes mouthwash or
toothpaste at that time they had ways of
cleaning their teeth but they would have
the most rank of breath so there is a
little creative license like they what
they want them to appear attractive on
screen like Tyrion is a good example to
during the Battle of Blackwater half of
his nose gets chopped off but when you
look at Peter Dinklage he just has a
minor scar so there's a big difference
between the books in the show the books
are a little true
were to what was actually like next
question Colin asks would you consider
the Hodor twist to be a bootstrap
paradox definitely I think there is a
causality loop going on just explain if
you don't know what a bootstrap paradox
is it just states that there's a paradox
in which an object or information can
exist without ever having been created
so as we're seeing it unfold
Hodor was already like this before
Willis had this accident when normally
that wouldn't make any sense because if
this is the first time brand has done
this
then how did Hodor become Hodor the
first time so that is the paradox a lot
of people also use the example of you
going back in time and becoming your own
father or grandfather
so just to drop an f-bomb it's one of
the great mind [ __ ] of the episode in
the series in general so they may never
explain that fully next question Sonny
asks can you explain the visions of
Danny in the house of the undying so
that there were a lot of things that she
saw that may have come to pass like an
alternate timeline situation and other
things from the past that are open to
interpretation if you've ever heard
people talk about MELAS Andrews visions
being very unreliable
she misinterprets them it's the same
situation with Daenerys like they tell
her when she goes in you will see things
that might have been so she has a vision
of her baby with Khal Drogo the stallion
who was supposed to mount the world but
as we know he ended up dying so what
she's seeing is an alternate timeline
where he did not die and there's a whole
bunch of stuff that she sees in the
books when she goes into the house of
the undying in the books there's a bunch
more going on in her visions than there
was on the TV show she has a vision of
her brother she hears the prophecy of
the prince who was promised the dragon
has three heads she also has a vision of
her brother dying at the Trident
whispering a woman's name you don't hear
what the name is but it's implied that
he's whispering lyanna stark's name as
rubies fly from his chest she sees a
blue flower growing from a chenkin of
all of ice previously a lot of people
felt like this was evidence of Jon
Snow's true parentage but now that we've
seen the night's king the way he was
created that could also be a version of
her seeing that as we see his blue eyes
bloom and if you were confused about
what's happening here when they're
creating the first night's king they're
actually shoving dragonglass into his
chest as they're speaking their
incantations her brother ray
our also speaks to her saying the dragon
must have three heads a lot of people
are taking that to mean that Daenerys
John Snow and Tyrion will be the three
heads of the Dragon they will ride the
three dragons the broader interpretation
in that Melisandre says that Jon Snow is
the one who was promised the High
Priestess says the same thing about
Daenerys just means that there is no one
person who is going to be the sole
savior of the world they're all going to
be working together
next question Ron asks if Brandon the
night's king have roughly the same
powers do you think that bran could
control the whites r.i.p Hodor
r.i.p summer no the way Dan and Dave
explained it at least the way they
interpreted on the show is that the
White Walkers were created from pure
evil so some of their magic is so evil
is probably not something that Brian is
going to try the actors and the
producers have said there are a lot of
powers that Brant has that we haven't
seen yet but I don't think that
controlling the whites is one of those
things
next question everyone asks while the
sudden was the night's king after bran
well I think he was after the three-eyed
Raven and Brant because they are so
powerful they could stop him potentially
their magic comes from the same place so
he probably has some connection to them
like he senses that they have power to
stop him so he wants to neutralize that
that was just my take away the night's
king has a pretty great intelligence so
he probably sees a threat and wants to
get rid of it next question deuces asks
do you think that Littlefinger wrote the
pink letter in the show with the come
and see line and he will use that to
gain the trust of Jon and Sansa and
control both the north and the Bale well
the way the director explained it for
that episode is they played it like
Ramsay wrote it so if Littlefinger wrote
the letter it's only in the books on the
TV show Ramsay wrote it Littlefinger is
an opportunist so I definitely think
that he wants to stay in Santa's good
graces he's gonna do everything he can
to make that happen but the way the
actor who plays Littlefinger talks about
it
he cares for Sansa so I don't think that
he's trying to be malicious in that way
he wants to control them in a sinister
way thank you everyone for submitting
questions though remember we're only
five episodes in so there's still a
whole bunch of reveals that they're
gonna do on the show I think that was
what people were worried about after the
three-eyed Raven died they're like are
we not going into the past anymore you
have to remember that bran can go into
the past on his own so that doesn't mean
we're never gonna see another flashback
again there are a couple things that
they still have to pay off
but most of the flashbacks that they've
been doing have seemingly paid off
things that lead up to big reveals from
Robert's rebellion in the night's king
so I'm definitely expecting them to save
the biggest reveals for the very last
episode for episode 10 but giveaway time
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner Noel a you win a $20 Amazon gift
card be sure to private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details that's on the about
page so there will be more Game of
Thrones this week but tonight is the
finale of the flash season 2 be sure to
watch it I'll post my video after the
episode airs those of you that are
asking about preacher
I'm totally gonna do a preacher video
for that first episode it's an amazing
comic book series it's so dark and
gritty I had to wait to watch it
after the Hodor moment because I was so
depressed I just had to wait a day or
two to watch preacher because it's super
dark while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here for my
episode 5 video and you can click here
for the R + L equals J refresher thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you